the niger delta is at the heart of
nigeria's oil industry
for which it has paid a price
environmental contamination
on a vast scale the all giant shell and
its nigerian subsidiary have always
denied any responsibility
but today a dutch court disagreed
siding with four nigerian farmers who
say their livelihoods were destroyed
by the leaks today justice
has prevailed we thank god and
we are still we are still calling
ourselves to come and do the necessary
so that livelihood will return back so
that we will live fine
their road to justice has been long it
began 13 years ago and since then two of
the farmers have
died including prince will's father ali
i'm very happy i'm very very happy yes
i'm very happy because
right now the common man in nigeria now
has hope
the case centers on two spills between
2004 and 2007
covering an area equivalent to 60
football pitches
the farmers filed their case in 2008 in
the netherlands
where royal dutch shell is headquartered
the company says the leaks were caused
by sabotage with both
sides appealing a ruling in 2013 but
today shell's nigerian subsidiary
was found responsible in order to pay
compensation
how much is to be decided for
environmentalists it is a key victory
those who live in the delta paint a
bleak picture to live
another data for short is to live in
hell
he gives hope to others whose livelihood
have been destroyed completely
it gives them hope that no matter how
long it takes
that justice will come for them one day
shell has said it's disappointed by the
ruling which could have ramifications
beyond nigeria
breaking new ground on how far
multinationals can be held
responsible for their actions overseas
it will open
maybe the gates for people to sue but i
think it will also mean that parent
companies will exercise
better control over their subsidiaries
and ensure
that best practices are put in place in
the same way as they do
in their home states
shell can still appeal the ruling so
this lengthy battle may yet continue
but for now those living in the niger
delta say they have hope
iva bennett sky news